welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who feels
like he's been talking about squid game
longer than illnam and this video we're
breaking down the series most mysterious
character throughout the season we as an
audience go on a bit of an emotional
roller coaster in which we laugh with
him cry over his death and then get the
reveal that he's actually been running
the entire thing it's difficult to not
get caught up in the ride that the show
takes us on and throughout this video
we'll be talking about the character's
origins history and also giving some of
the fan theories surrounding him this
includes a big new clue that's just been
discovered which makes it seem like he's
indeed related to kihun now before we
get into it if you could do me a big
favor and smash that like button and
also don't forget to subscribe for
videos like this every week because yes
i'm gonna write squid game into the
ground 17 million views baby i'm richer
than illness anyway without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the video
okay so episode 9 is where the truth
about illness starts to unravel after
not spending any of his winnings gehan
is given the address to a building where
he comes across the character laying on
his deathbed illness reveals the truth
about himself and this also confirms
that he does have a brain tumor as many
of you know illness translates roughly
to number one man and this does some
more time to the character's number
which we'll talk about later on now
throughout the series we learn a lot
about illness past when he was growing
up the character barely had any money
but what he did have was a love for
games this included red light green
light the honeycomb challenge marbles
hopscotch and of course squid game
illness was absolutely fascinated with
them and to top it off he was a great
player of them all which tied into his
love of gambling and well gaming now
illness came from very humble beginnings
and at one point in the series we come
across a recreation of his house during
the marbles game the character admits
that he used to hide behind a post and
watch his children play games which he
would have absolutely loved to have
played himself this very much hints
towards the future in which he set up
the squid games and deep down had a need
to get involved in them now illness
wasn't exactly the best husband and
though his wife used to make him meals
that we see being eaten in the series he
definitely put his own enjoyment above
his family illness used to also beat his
son for doing things like asking for
chocolate milk and we'll talk about how
this could hint towards him being
related to gihon later on either way we
can tell by just how few people there
are around his deathbed that he and his
family became very estranged whenever he
talks about them in the series it's
always as if they're not waiting for him
on the outside and because of this we
can conclude that they haven't seen each
other in a while because of his choices
this is of course reflected in gihon who
remained behind at the end of the series
instead of going to see his daughter now
where elon made his fortune was lending
money charging interest and then
basically holding people to ransom for
the rest of their lives we see gihon on
the opposite side of this where he's
constantly chased by loan sharks and it
is possible that they're working for
ilnam and basically starving the people
of the city so that they're desperate
enough to actually enter the games
quickly ilnam amassed a vast fortune of
wealth and this very much improved his
life however he found himself extremely
bored and unable to really find
enjoyment anymore getting the money that
he wanted meant that he no longer wanted
for nothing and it completely removed
any aspect of challenge in his life
looking back on his childhood and
remembering the funny had playing games
illness spoke to other people in similar
situations around the world and they all
felt exactly the same they realized that
no longer struggling had removed any
satisfaction from their life and thus
everything became hollow thus they
pooled their resources and started
tournaments around the world that would
recruit players into a game of life and
death the squid game was born and it
lasted for decades and decades everyone
in the operation other than the players
wore masks and thus there was an
anonymity to the proceedings that meant
it flew under the radar now the masks in
the show all hold some significance not
only did they denote rank but they also
carry the idea of spirit animals and so
on the most slowly people down the pole
all have smooth masks with barely any
curves whereas the further up the
hierarchy you go the more edges there
are this ranks from the soldiers all the
way up to the front man to the vips and
then of course illness illness wears an
owl mask and typically this is thought
to embody wisdom and also a cunning side
to someone's personality these are
skills that ilnam clearly possesses and
the masks have all been chosen for a
reason the siberian tiger is actually
the national animal of south korea and
there is potential that the person we
see wearing this is a political figure
the bull typically denotes stocks and
finances and the deer are thought to be
divine animals that walk between the
spirit and natural world illness
believes himself to be above all but
it's only upon entering the games and
seeing gihan's kindness firsthand that
he takes off the mask backstage and
decides to step away from everything now
money lending clearly made illness see
the ugly side of life and oppressing
people made him completely disregard the
value of humans he sees them more as
play things and just in the same way
that people bet on horses not seeing the
life there he didn't really see the life
in humanity everyone in the games was
given a number much like the horses and
left to fight it out whilst the vips
looked on however i do believe the games
changed illness and even though in his
final breaths it seems like he's someone
who still disregards humanity i believe
this final game is to teach gihon a
lesson now if he wins and someone
doesn't come to save the homeless person
it might inspire you hun to use the
fortune to help others if he'll now
loses then gihon will see there's still
good in the world and carry out this
plan anyway
i must admit that's very much me
guessing at that but illness always
seems one step ahead of everyone else
and i believe he knew kihun well enough
to know the path that he would take
after this game it's exactly why he
called him to his deathbed as he showed
him kindness in the games that other
people didn't on his deathbed it's clear
that he appreciates gihan and says that
thanks to him he got to remember the joy
he had in the past and it's a truly
emotional scene now going beyond this
we've talked in the past about how ilnam
and gihon could be related in case
you've missed those videos which what
the hell are you doing there are a
number of clues including the chocolate
milk conversation that the two share as
mentioned earlier ilnam says that he
used to beat his son for doing this and
it's clear that he hun very much
remembers that happening maybe not him
but moving on now when looking at his
house during marbles kihon also says
that an alleyway in the mock-up looks
extremely similar to where he used to
live to top this off there's been a new
clue discovered and this seems to show
that they are indeed related now as we
learned throughout the show ilnam's full
name is o'ilnam surnames auraverse in
korean culture and therefore the o is
actually his last name now engi hun
steals his mother's credit card at the
start of the show we can actually catch
her name for a split second and it
starts with oh hinting at their
relationship in this series ilnam also
asks if it's the 24th as that means his
son's birthday is coming up soon now
where it gets interesting is that after
stealing his mother's credit card gihon
enters his birthday as the pin and this
number is zero four two six now we know
that the games take place in april and
that counts for the zero four if the two
six means 26 then that means gee hun's
birthday is the 26th of april which does
put it pretty close to the 24th now
these could all simply be coincidences
but i am someone that does kinda hope
that they are related as it just adds
another layer to the show gihan of
course ends up turning his back on his
family in order to go back to the games
and this is somewhat similar to ilnam
who did the same thing ilnam is very
much a cautionary tale in the show and
watching his son potentially following
in his father's footsteps just adds a
whole other layer to the series that i'd
love to see explored later down the line
either way that's my thoughts on it and
obviously i'd love to hear yours in the
comments below we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the phase three mcu
boxer on the 30th of october and all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the video we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of all the
easter eggs hidden details and things
you missed in squid game it's one of our
best videos ever and it's definitely
worth checking out right after this
without the way thank you for sticking
through this one i've been paul and
hopefully i'll see you next time you
take care of yourself enjoy the rest of
your week and have a good one much love
peace